à 21h10 view arnaud penser à croire à ce
moment là comme comme d'habitude à rien
quand vous regardez le matin dans la
glace vous vous dites quoi je me regarde
pas je me rase super mal et sur des
trucs qui reste un peu ici et là voilà
mais là aussi vous dit rien non vous
commencez à réfléchir vers quelle heure
il est quelle heure là vous vous auriez
aimé ressembler à qui quand vous étiez
petit quand j'étais petit james bond ou
cary grant aux plus belles histoires
d'amour c'est là qu'elle
j'aime bien comme il aime bien qu'on
réussisse à oui il était malade je suis
parti j'ai dû rentrer une semaine en
france
j'ai confié une dame quand je suis
rentré il et qui tous mais il avait
attrapé un virus
j'ai séché l'armée en chercher de vue
j'ai fait quatre vétérinaires et il
connaît l'histoire du mec alors son
chien qu'il confie à un pote
non il lui dit écoute je pars quinze
jours en vacances c'est mon chat c'est
mon frère tu tournes occupé tout
vraiment j'ai totalement confiance en
toi et tous et il rentre qu'un jour
après 10 hamas s'est bien passé les
vacances super et où il dit mon chat il
est où est son petit bâton chat il est
mort ils sont déconnectés comment ça
s'est passé il se met à hurler à chialer
toit puis libyen t'es con tu savais que
j'adorais ce chat tu aurais pu me
préparer l'autre il y attend entre
chiens il est mort qu'est ce que tu veux
que je te dise
bah tu aurais pu me dire
le ch avec un bouchon le bouchon il a
roulé sur le balcon l'échelle elle
essayait d'attraper la bascule et voilà
et ma grand-mère tapé ma grand mère tu
as des nouvelles de ma grand-mère bats
ta mère grand-mère a duré qu'un bouchon
bouchardeau licence balcon
quand avez vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois mon plus tap atx et avec mon père
et mon père me fais taper plein de
choses super triste quoi toujours très
souvent et parfois je tape mécaniquement
et parfois je tape
en mettant la place des gens que des
gens qui sont morts aux clients souffert
et parfois il m'arrive de ne changeriez
quoi en vous si vous aviez une baguette
magique
oh la la c'est un bâton vas-y qua non il
n'est pas pourtant de la taille de son
sexe est devenu un bâton magique
tellement de choses
ouais beaucoup c'est trop trop long à
lisser quoi qu'est ce que vous pouvez
dire de plus négatif sur vos arnaud et
devrais je suis égoïste
quelle est l'insulté qui vous a fait le
plus mal
j'en entendu tellement que vraiment je
suis comme un canard avec de l'eau too
big to be souhaité aller au meeting du
front national c'est dur d'entendre nom
bre j'ai surtout un reçu des coups quoi
les insultes je m'en foutais un peu
quelles que soient les insultes douze
ans passés à tabac ouais tapez 1 tapez 1
tapez et puis j'étais comme ça en bullet
et 5 ils font inquiéter avec toi qui
t'es avec toi alors je me suis dit
penser amicalement vôtre de noailles
george p donald le canard pourtant c'est
de la bonne vanne
ouais mais dans les situations comiques
est pas bon tu peux faire ce que tu veux
tu vois le public il est apprécié leur
bible est le plus cité faiblissait qui
avez vous le plus envie d'épater dans la
vie arnaud sort du bon père qu est la
dernière chose que vous faites avant de
vous coucher
j'enlève les miettes du lit si vous
restez 24 heures à vivre je jetterai ma
montre pas mal quelle est la dernière
personne que vous ayez envie de tuer je
peux violent quand vous le coiffeur
quand même ça fout les boules 1
quel est donc ce que nous ne sachions
pas j'étais j'avais 13 ans j'étais avec
ma mère on voyage dans l ai trouvé des
petits canards et je dormais avec le
petit canard et dans la nuit j'ai écrasé
le petit canard alors je me suis
retrouvé avec le petit canard mort et je
me suis sentie tellement coupable
j'ai pris mon petit canard et j'ai mis
dans le lean ma mère
d'abord c'est vrai et ma mère ma mère
est plus utile c'était moi qui l'avais
écrasé de quelle question aimeriez vous
avoir la réponse
est ce que le canard a pas trop souffert
de quelques questions parce que
l'univers est fini ou infini
ouais je sais moi à temps gelé noté iata
qu'est ce que la vie vous a appris
jusqu'à maintenant eu alors la caméra au
brossez vous les dents
ayez de l' enthousiasme de l'énergie ne
vous droguez pas trop ne fumait pas
pensez à ceux qui sont plus malheureux
bout hockey dans la zone bah pas mal de
choses comme ça m'effraie on apprend sur
le tard ou alors on a beaucoup de mettre
la ceinture à l'avant et à l'arrière
jouer est-ce que vous avez une meilleure
opinion de vous qu'à l'âge de 20 ans bon
un peu mieux
non mais cette idée là de partir en
israël dans l'armée ça c'est courageux
quand même
ouais mais après c'est derrière quoi
ouais une vue je pense plus ouais et on
sera au dans deux mois je sais je sais
pas comment aimeriez-vous mourir en
bonne santé
ouais vous avez menti là durant cette
interview non non non je mens pas c'est
vrai vous avez pas l'air d'un avocat un
territoire